[MUSIC]
I'm Jules van Binsbergen, the Nippon Life
Professor in Finance at the Wharton School
at the University of Pennsylvania.
>> And I'm Jonathan Berk,
the AP Giannini Professor of Finance at
the Graduate School of Business
at Stanford University.
And we hope you'll join us on a journey
where we explore the science and
strategy of better decision-making
on All Else Equal,
a new podcast from the Stanford Graduate
School of Business and the Wharton School.
>> Together we have been teaching and
studying business decision-making for
over 40 years.
And in that time, we've learned about
the most common mistakes that people make.
And we've also learned a thing or
two about how to explain those mistakes to
decision makers, particularly after
having made them repeatedly ourselves.
>> In this podcast series, we'll look
at the ways people make mistakes,
and how we can learn from their mistakes.
We'll talk to business leaders about
choices they have had to make.
And we'll show you a framework you can
use to become a better decision maker,
not just on the job, but
in your personal life as well.
>> Over the years, one of the things we
have found is that abstract theoretical
concepts just don't resonate with people.
What does resonate are concrete examples,
and
that insight is the basis of
the case method in business schools.
By explaining a general principle in
the context of an interesting example,
the ideas become interesting and
fun to talk about.
It is also how people remember ideas.
There's lots of research that shows that
concreteness is key to how the brain
stores ideas.
>> In each podcast, we'll discuss
specific interesting examples.
And we'll invite successful leaders to
talk about their personal experience
making the mistake,
why it was so costly, and
how they try to avoid them in the future.
>> And so in our first few episodes,
we will explore a number of business
decision-making situations where ignoring
the reaction of the world around
you leads to the wrong decision.
This is why we've decided to
call the podcast All Else Equal.
>> When you make a decision,
the world around you reacts.
It's not just the world
is constantly changing,
it is the world changes because
of the decisions you make.
>> This type of all else equal
thinking is the common thread through
the podcast series.
Make sure to catch each
episode by following or
subscribing to our show wherever
you listen to your podcasts.
For more information and episodes,
visit allelseequalpodcast.com.
[MUSIC]